alors un des éléments de stratégie que
je veux qu'il ya quelques secondes qu'il
faut absolument mettre en oeuvre pour la
france métropolitaine mais aussi pour
les outre-mer c'est le contrôle aux
frontières des territoires
moi je crois totalement irresponsable de
laisser entrer sur le territoire des
légendes qui ne sont pas vaccinés en
fait le fait de laisser passer des gens
non vaccinés mais à bas toute politique
de comptes de deux ans l'anglais du
containment de maintien de contrôle de
l'épidémie
je sais que la publicité gouvernementale
veut dire qu on a atteint nos objectifs
mais pas du tout le 21 janvier et le
ministre oliver en disait fin juillet
nous aurons 57 millions de gens vaccinés
on n'y est pas donc on voit qu'on est en
permanence dans l'improvisation parce
que il ya parce que c'est un mélange
d'amateurisme d'une expérience en tout
cas tentative de pédagogie de
communication certains ont besoin
emmanuel macron qui de détente en de
brégançon tente de rassurer les jeunes
de répondre aux questions de contrer
aussi les rumeurs ça ça vous convainc
pas il n'y a pas eu une seule campagne
de d'informations sérieuses sur la
vaccination depuis le mois de janvier
pas moins
c'est quoi une campagne sérieuse c'est
une campagne qui explique aux gens qui
ont peur de se faire vacciner il ya des
jours comme ça pourquoi ils ont tort
d'avoir peur en leur donnant des
arguments pas en montrant une grand-mère
qui embrasse ses petits enfants
moi je crois beaucoup à ça il n'y a pas
eu de vraie campagne d'information alors
après que le président de la république
mouiller le maillot pour informer
pourquoi pas là où je suis un peu
sceptique c'est la mise en scène et sur
le niveau de sincérité
voilà du tic toc et duty shops tee shirt
qui vous gêne non mais c'est plutôt
l'ensemble quel est le niveau de
sincérité quel est le véritable emmanuel
macron est-ce que c'est celui de youtube
heures et de tik tok
ou est-ce que c'est celui qui grondait
voir un peu humilié un collégien au mont
valérien 2018 en lui disant surtout tu
ne dit qu'il ne m'appelle pas manu oui
tu ne m'appelle pas manu mais en
revanche je vais faire des galipettes
enfin pas le président les youtube
heures sur la pelouse de l'elysée il ya
ce double visage qui est ce vrai qui
c'est vrai moi me pose problème